字幕: kanami Nagano
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
私は スポーツを通じて
豊かな世の中を作るため
日々活動しています
時には 世界最高峰の障害物レースに
出たりもします
しかし 私は子供の頃
運動音痴で大の運動嫌いでした
嘘でしょうと思われる方も
いるかもしれませんが 本当なんです
幼少の頃 初めてのボール投げで
ボールをキャッチできず
顔面で受け 思いっきり鼻血を流しました
けれどその私が今
財団の代表を務め
子供たちと一緒に
思いっきり体を動かし
スポーツは豊かな世の中を
つくることができると信じて
活動しているのですから 自分でも驚きです
なぜこれほどまで
スポーツの力を信じられるようになったのか
そこには 私が大切にしている—
人は変化に対応し進化することで成長する
という考え方があるのです
私は福島県いわき市の商店街にあった
紳士服店の２階で生まれました
１階の店舗では 父が仕入れをし
母が販売をし
私は２、３歳の頃まで
店頭にあるワゴンに紐でつながれ
お客様に「いらっしゃいませ」
「ありがとうございました」 と
いわば 看板犬ならぬ 看板娘でした
父が立ち上げた小さな紳士服店は
次々と出店し 拡大していきました
そして その後
二転三転、四転五転と
当時はカメレオンカンパニーと言われるほど
業態を変化させていきました
ですから 父が会社で言うことは
日々変わりました
昨日言ったことは今日変わり
今日言ったことも
明日には変わるという感じです
なぜそうコロコロ言うことが変わるのかと
質問すると 父は
「世の中は常に変化する
その変化に対応し
進化した者こそ生き残る」
そう話してくれました
私はというと
小さい時から転校や引っ越しで
「こんにちは さようなら」の日々
そんな生活に慣れるうち
中学校の終わりの頃には
自ら福島を飛び出し
仙台、 東京、 サンディエゴ
ボストン、 バルセロナと
28歳の頃まで飛び回っていました
しかし 私が最も尊敬し信頼する父は
ある日突然 旅行先で亡くなりました
今から15年前 2003年のことです
経営のことはもちろん
人としての生き方を教えてくれた父でしたので
私の心には ぽっかり大きな穴が空き
全く現実味がありませんでした
父が教えてくれたことは
人は変化に対応し
進化することで成長する ということを
ずっと教えてくれてましたので
私が生まれた時から
その考えは私のそばにあったのです
そして
2011年3月11日 東日本大震災です
父の実家は福島県いわき市
母の実家は宮城県石巻市で
私は多くの親戚 友人 知人を失いました
さらには 経営していたスポーツ店70店舗が
倒壊し 破損しました
実は あの時の記憶は
今でも断片的です
確実に覚えているのは
心から生きていたいと思ったこと
生きているということは奇跡であり
そうして生かされた私に
何ができるのかということを考え始めました
倒壊した店舗で最初に始めたのは
70店舗から
テント キャンプ用品を取り出し
そして 地域の人々が集まれる
場所を作りました
しかし そこの場所にいた子供たちからは
すっかり笑顔が消えていました
親、兄弟、 親戚
そして家までも失った子供たちですから
笑顔が出るはずもありませんよね
そんな中 支援の輪が広がり
世界中から多くのアスリートも
支援に来てくれました
ある日私は
NBAのレジェンドプレイヤーと共に
宮城県塩釜市立の中学校に
行くことがありました
何人かの子供たちは その日まで
ボールを触ることさえ拒んでいました
レジェンドに背中を押され
ボールでパスを始めた時
それまで無表情だった子供たちに
笑顔が戻り 涙を流し始めたのです
今でも鮮明に覚えています
これほど苦しい状況にあっても
スポーツには人を笑顔にする力がある
生きる力を与えてくれる力がある
そう強く感じたのです
それまでの私は
スポーツはスポーツが好きな人
スポーツができる人だけのものだと
思っていました
しかし 無表情だった子供たちの変化を見た時
スポーツの持つ力を実感したのです
そして その子供たちを見た時
スポーツが生活の中にあることで
人生がより感動的で楽しくなる
そして そういう人が
たくさん増えることで
より豊かな世の中が
作られるのではないか
それは衝撃的な発見でした
今ここにいる子供たちのために
出来ることをやっていこう という
エネルギーが湧いてきたのです
このことが 財団設立のきっかけとなりました
私たちの最初の活動は
放射能問題で 外に出られない
子どもたちのための
無料の運動施設の開設でした
実は震災後 福島の子供たちの肥満率は
一気に増加しました
子供たちが外で遊ぶ
体を動かすという当たり前のことが
これほど重要なことか
私は改めて実感することになります
そして 財団は活動の場を広げ
様々なスポーツイベントを企画し
今では60万人以上の子供たちに
スポーツの機会を提供しています
中でも最も力を入れているのが
小学生を対象とした スポーツキャンプです
２泊３日 子供たちだけで過ごし
様々な競技の元日本代表選手
プロアスリートに直接指導を行ってもらい
夜は英語での交流会を行うなど
子どもたちは様々な体験をします
このキャンプでは時々
いや ほぼ毎回 事件が起こります
初日は緊張している子どもたちも
２日目になるとリラックス—
したかと思うと 喧嘩勃発
挙句の果てに 上手くいかないことに腹を立て
大暴れしたかと思うと
大脱走
(笑）
キャンプに参加しているボランティア
我々スタッフは ある意味死に物狂いです
それでもある子は キャンプを振り返って
「自分にできる競技は一つだけでなく
たくさんあることを知った」
またある子は
「キャンプに参加して
初めての人とも
積極的に話が出来るようになった」と
話してくれました
２泊３日というわずかな時間ですが
スポーツキャンプが子供たちの成長に
大きな影響を与えていることを
私はとても嬉しく感じています
そして 今では確信しています
私が大切にしている—
「人は変化に対応し
進化することで成長する」ということに
スポーツが大きな力を与えているということを
私は先日 ブエノスアイレスで開催された—
第１回「Olympism in Action Forum」 に
参加してきました
そこには ５大陸 150ヵ国
1500人以上の人が集まり
スポーツの力で平和な社会をつくるため
様々なトピックで
ディスカッションが行われました
スポーツが国際社会を継続的に
より良い方向に発展させるため
2020年に開催される東京オリンピック
パラリンピック以降も
日本が担う役割は
とても大きなものがあると思っています
チャレンジすることを怖がらず
様々なことをして進化し
仲間と影響しあって成長する
子供たちがスポーツを通じて
そういった体験をできる場を
これからも作っていきたいと思っています
私は幼少の頃から
変化の人生を過ごしてきました
そして 父の死で事業を受け継ぎ
東日本大震災で多くを失い
絶望の淵に立たされました
それでも 今この日を迎えています
それは その時々の変化を受け入れ
自分自身に力をつけ
進化し 成長してきたからに
他ならないと思うのです
今日この会場にお越しの皆さんも
日々 変化し、進化し、成長して
今を迎えていることと思います
時には辛く苦しい出来事に
立ち止まってしまい
前に踏み出せない日もあるでしょう
けれど 進化したことで
出来なかったことが出来るようになる喜びは
何事にも変えがたいと
私は思うのです
そうすることで 自分なりの
幸せな人生を送ることができると
私は身をもって感じています
変化、進化、成長
皆さんも是非 今よりも一歩
前に踏み出してみてください
ありがとうございました
(拍手）